Right here's all the footage for the Sam and Niko channel.
Right click, delete.
We’ve been looking to fix the camera room up for a while.
So we just got back from home depot, Derek and I.
And, uh,  we’ve just realised, upon building the shelves, that the raid is still in there.
The raid is basically the drive that everything that corridor has ever done.
That’s pretty important.
Like how did this ha- how did this happen?
The computer that the most people depend on, on a regular basis,
that never gets shut off, is sitting here, shoved into a corner like an abandoned child.
It’s the culmination of all of our hard work, forever.
I know. But luckily it’s in my hands. So, we’re good.
Look at the cable management in there.
Don't look at- look at that.
Oh no!
It’s terrible.
Hi!
Corridor Digital.
Is this the right entrance?
Yes.
OK. I wasn’t sure.
Today, it’s Monday morning and we’re at the DJI LA headquarters.
The Mavic from DJI
Today, we’re going to meet with some of our buddies here at DJI.
The purpose of our visit today is- well I don’t know really what it is.
They told us they had something to show us so we decided to come in and see what that is.
Hopefully it’s a drone.
They wanted to give us the Mavic, but they also wanted to give us a non pre-production model.
but they also wanted to give us a non pre-production model.
Like they wanted to give us like the final thing that isn’t going to like break down.
In most of the videos you see online, Youtubers, when they get like a product or something
before anyone else does, usually that product is like a prototype model or a beta model.
It will work for about a month or two, but the moment someone updates firmware
they’re out of business. We just want stuff that works.
Cleaning out the raid ‘cause it hasn’t been done in fucking forever.
Yep. Now that the raid is clean, we’re going to get it all set up nice and fresh.
Give it it’s own little desk in there and set up the rest of the room.
The most powerful computer in the whole building has the worst fucking cables ever.
Something no one ever fucking took the time to do.
Been in this studio since 2014. Haven’t had a fucking cable that's actually been managed.
*Indesiriaphable singing*
Man, what are we missing on?
I don’t know. They’re doing some serious work and we’re like two people trying to put one camera together.
Been in the studio since 2014...
Been in the studio...
Who’s going to manage the cables now?
Why the fuck hasn’t this fucking bullshit been done?
Corridor: the musical.
Look at Wren out there. What’s he doing?
Film business usually seems pretty glamorous.
Oh man you get to work with big actors and blow things up and make things look all pretty
and once in awhile, you get to do that. Most of it is phone calls and conference meetings
and sitting there slogging through a script, trying to figure out what you can afford to shoot
and how you’re going to problem solve all this kind of stuff.
There’s already a lot of content you can watch on YouTube and if we’re just going to do more of the same,
then there’s no point in people watching this on YouTube RED.
If you’re going to tell a good story that hooks people, you’re going to dig into emotions both good and bad.
It really falls into like classic pillars of like noir cinema.
Not saying this is black and white hard-boiled detectives. I'm calling it, I guess, neo-noir.
Playing around with with a lot of more like the moodier aspects that you get from that kind of cinema.
We were on the phone with some folks over at YouTube and we have some YouTube influences in this piece.
It’s going to help it get some publicity, help people tune in, because it’s going to going on YouTube RED.
We’re steering a little bit away from the vlogger perspective
and trying to get a little more to the sketch artist and actor side of things.
For example; Julian Smith is another guy that kind of sticks out.
Brother.
I’m not going to drink it.
I made this for you.
No.
I MADE THIS FOR YOU!
...brings characters to life regularly- uhm so you know in terms of, uh-
Today in the behind-the-scenes of the behind-the-scenes we delete a lot of shit.
The storage unit right here is red and that storage unit is the raid.
Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on.
If this raid was to be deleted, we would lose everything.
Right here’s all the footage for the Sam and Niko channel.
Right click.
Delete.
And yes.
We started at 99 gigabytes and by deleting about 3 months worth of behind the scenes footage,
I just gave everyone 1.5 terabytes
You’re welcome, Wren.
That was a direct hit, dude!